Hallo, Chaosradio Express, die sechste Ausgabe, unerwartet, schnell nachgeliefert, denn ich habe einen unerwarteten Gast und das ist der Sascha. Und mit Sascha werde ich mich heute über Telefon unterhalten. Im Hintergrund hören wir noch mal einen weiteren Mix von Sonic Walker. Ja, über Telefon unterhalten. Aber ich unterhalte mich nicht über Telefon mit ihm, sondern ich unterhalte mich mit ihm über Telefon.
Das gleiche Wortspiel hatte ich mir gerade auch schon zurechtgelegt im Kopf. War ich wohl langsamer?
Genau. Sascha hat hier sein eigenes Mikrofon am Start. Deswegen haben wir heute maximale Audio-Fadility, was auch daran liegt, dass er gute meine Erfahrungen hat. Sehe schon, er greift mir immer schön immer Maßregeln in die Regler. Und wir haben jetzt auch unsere Kompressoren richtig konfiguriert, damit man hier mal richtig schreien kann.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass das hier alles so gut funktioniert und dass wir jetzt eine feine Sendung einfach mal machen.
Genau, wir wollen uns nämlich auch noch mal ein bisschen über den Kongress unterhalten, aber unter einem bestimmten Aspekt. Ich habe es ja schon in der vorletzten Sendung erwähnt, Sascha ist vom POC, wie wir das nennen, vom Phone Operation Center, kümmert sich also um die Telefon-Technologie, die bei dem Kongress auf dem Einsatz ist. Das hat auch so eine gewisse Geschichte und die fing an vor, wie lange ist das jetzt her? Zwei Jahren?
Nein, auf dem HAL ging es eigentlich schon damals los in Holland.
Stimmt, vor vier Jahren.
Da hatten wir Telefonanlage mit, eigentlich nur aus…
Ich möchte kurz nochmal erwähnen, was HAL ist. Also HAL, Hackers at Large, ist die dritte, vierte?
Ich glaube die dritte.
2001 auf jeden Fall das große Hackercamp in…
Enschede?
Genau, in Enschede. Und dort wart ihr am Start mit Telefontechnik. Was hattet ihr damals dabei?
Das war eigentlich auch erst nur aus dem Spaß heraus. Wir waren halt mit zehn Leuten da, hatten uns ein kleines Zelt geholt, sind dann da hingefahren und haben gedacht, ja, wenn wir schon mal da sind, dann nehmen wir einfach mal die kleine Telefonanlage mit, kleine Anführungszeichen. Sowas habe ich halt in entsprechenden Größenordnungen irgendwann mal gefunden, weil ich tagtäglich solche Anlagen baue und haben gesagt, komm, nehmen wir einfach mal mit, kann man ein bisschen mit rumspielen.
Das war kreative Resteverwertung.
Ja, genau, und dann ging es dann so am ersten Tag erstmal darum, haben wir die Telefonanlage aufgestellt, dann haben wir in unserem Zelt so drei, vier Telefone installiert. Man will ja dann nicht von einem zum anderen Ende schreien, sondern man möchte ja dann auch irgendwie mal den anderen anrufen können.
Aber wenn du Telefone sagst, dann reden wir nicht von Telefon am Kabel, sondern wir reden von schnurlosen Telefonen.
Nee, das waren erstmal Festtelefone, die wir ins Zelt gestellt haben. Und dann ging es dann los. Dann haben wir erst eine Decktantenne, so eine Basisstation, aufgehangen bei uns im Zelt. Und dann konnte man zumindest schon mal im Umkreis so von 200 Metern telefonieren. Dann haben wir überlegt, ja, wir haben da noch so eine Kiste, da liegen noch vier weitere Basisstationen drin. Was kann man damit noch machen?
Und die habt ihr dann alle angeschlossen?
Genau, und sind wir kurzerhand ins Field Headquarter gegangen und haben uns da mehrere hundert Meter Cut-Kabel erschnort.
Also Field Headquarter ist da, wo das Computernetzwerk eigentlich geplant wird.
Genau, und dann gibt es halt Kabel, wenn man dann sagt, ja, ich habe hier meinen Computer und den möchte ich jetzt gerne ins Internet bringen, dann bekommt man da ein Kabel, aber keine Strecken über 95 Meter, weil das geht ja nicht. Wir brauchten auf einmal 150 Meter und dann guckten sie uns natürlich ganz doll an. Wir so, doch, doch, doch, das geht schon, wir machen da Deckantennen dran. Ja, und so ging es dann los. Dann haben wir dann immer weiter die Strecken gemacht und irgendwann hatte man so auf dem halben Kampfgelände eigentlich relativ guten Deckdempfang schon.
Und wie viele Leute haben dann da telefoniert?
Das waren im Endeffekt glaube ich zehn Leute oder so was, die die halt wussten, ja, bringt mal Schnurlos-Telefone mit.
Also eine wahre Dekadenzinstallation.
Ja.
So, und dann ging das aber weiter. Also ich habe das ja persönlich wahrgenommen, als ihr dann auf dem Camp aufgekreuzt seid vor zwei Jahren. Da hatten wir ja schon uns entschlossen, das mit in unsere Infrastruktur mit einzubauen, weil ihr da großspurig aufgekreuzt seid und gesagt habt, das kriegen wir schon alles hin. Und es hat ja dann auch super geklappt. Wie war da die Ausbaustufe?
Die war eigentlich schon recht gut. Wir hatten damals noch das Problem, dass wir in eine einzige Anlage nicht so viele Systempartien reinbekommen. Daher wäre die Kapazität eigentlich nicht groß gewesen. Wir haben aber kurz eine zweite Anlage dabei gebaut und die miteinander vernetzt. So haben wir in die eine Anlage den ganzen Deckkram getan, für die schnurlosen Telefone, und in das andere Anlagenteil quasi die ganzen Telefone, die ganzen Festnetztelefone, die so überall verteilt waren auf dem Campgelände.
Lass uns doch mal kurz diese Decktechnik nochmal machen. Ich meine, das ist etwas, was, glaube ich, ich meine, es ist extrem verbreitet. Ganz viele haben das, aber niemand kennt das so sehr auch unter dem technischen Begriff wie ISDN zum Beispiel. Das ist ja ein deutlich höherer Bekanntheitsgrad. Zumindest meine Wahrnehmung. Was ist an dem DECT dran, dass das für solche großen Installationen so geeignet ist? Man ist doch eigentlich nur fürs Wohnzimmer gedacht.
Ja, ursprünglich, ich weiß nicht, ob es unbedingt fürs Wohnzimmer entwickelt worden ist. Also diejenigen, die es entwickelt haben, haben da glaube ich schon ein bisschen weiter gedacht, dass man da so Sachen wie Handover machen können möchte. Das heißt also von der einen Basisstation zur nächsten Basisstation wechseln, mit einem laufenden Gespräch.
Das, was man beim Handy-Roaming nennen würde.
Und ich denke, die haben da schon eine gute Sache erfunden, mehr oder weniger. Oder zumindest das versucht, in einen Standard zu pressen. Und dieses Ding nennt sich dann GAP, Generic Access Profile. Und das regelt so ein bisschen die Art und Weise, wie ein Deckt-Handy sich in einem Deckt-System zu verhalten hat.
Und letztlich wird das ja auch in großen Firmen eingesetzt, nicht wahr? Firmennetze.
Richtig, da gibt es also reichlich große Installationen auch. Es gibt zum Beispiel so ein Klebe- und Waschmittelhersteller aus Düsseldorf, der hat, ich glaube, Andi 10.000 Schnurlohstelefone in dieser Installation in seinem Firmenstandort in Düsseldorf. Und da funktioniert das auch ganz gut.
Stammf, Stammf, die Musik schreitet voran, wir auch. Was ist denn jetzt eure Technik, die ihr konkret am Start habt? Also ihr habt ja da so eine eigene Telefonanlage.
Genau, wobei eigene ist halt nur vom besitzrechtlichen her, eigene. Alles andere ist also richtige Telco-Technik, die man auch in großen Firmen einsetzt.
Also ist nicht selbst gebaut, sondern selbst zusammengesteckt.
Ganz genau, ja. Und zwar ist das eine Alcatel Omni-PCX-Office, schimpft die sich in der bunten Produktbezeichnung. Intern heißt die einfach 44 00, weil den Franzosen, weiß nicht, nichts anderes eingefallen ist oder so, weil Alcatel grundsätzlich alles irgendwie mit Namen, mit Nummern betitelt. Egal, ob es jetzt Netzwerk-Komponenten, Kabel, Strecken oder sonst irgendwas ist. Alles hat irgendeine Nummer bei denen.
Und wie ist da die Ausbaustufe? Also was kann das Ding so in etwa?
Das System kann alleine als einzeln stehende Anlage, so grob über den Daumen gepeilt, also 5000 Festtelefone verwalten und so eine Anzahl von, sagen wir mal, 10.000 bis 15.000 Decktandys als eigene, einzelnen, ständige Anlage. Wenn man mehr haben will, kein Problem, nimmt man einfach mehrere Anlagen und vernetzt die alle miteinander. Und dann kann man auch solche Großinstallationen auch netzübergreifend, weltübergreifend andere Länder halt bauen.
10.000 bis 15.000?
Genau, pro Anlage so.
Na dann kann der Kongress ja noch ein bisschen wachsen.
Gut, da müsste man entsprechend dann Hardware halt einbauen, wo dann die Telefone drauf terminieren, aber machbar ist das.
Okay, wir haben es schon erwähnt, die Technik kommt auf dem nächsten Kongress wieder zum Einsatz. Was heißt das jetzt konkret für die Teilnehmer? Also man kann sein eigenes Decktelefon mitnehmen, kann man auch welche erwerben vor Ort?
Das ist bisher noch nicht so ganz klar. Da müssen wir mal gucken, ob wir da vielleicht so einen ähnlichen Deal hinbekommen, wie wir auf der What the Heck in Holland hatten. Da hatten wir relativ günstig Decktelefone bekommen, die wir dann verkauft haben.
Ansonsten gibt es ja noch den Saturn gegenüber.
Richtig, und wie du im letzten Express schon sagtest, kann man natürlich von seinem Umtausch recht Gebrauch machen.
Falls einem das Gerät nicht gefällt.
Richtig.
Aber nur dann natürlich.
Ja, ansonsten soll man es natürlich behalten und auch benutzen.
Klar.
Und ansonsten hat man auch auf dem 23C3 natürlich noch die Möglichkeit, das Telefon wieder zu benutzen.
Ja, das heißt, ich komme dahin und dann weiß ja eigentlich erst mal eure Telefonanlage nichts von mir. Also muss ich zuallererst zu eurem Tresen marschieren. Richtig?
Richtig.
Dann sage ich, hallo, ich bin der Tim und ich hätte gerne Telefonnummer sowieso. Die kann man ja auch vorher schon reservieren in dem GURUSYSTEM unter eventphone.de und dann bucht man sein Telefon ein. Was müsst ihr dafür dann tun?
Also wenn es irgendwie so ein Standard-Telefon ist, die großen bekannten zwei Hersteller, die es da gibt, die es auch überall zu kaufen gibt, da ist die Menüführung meistens bei den aktuellen Teilen so einfach, dass es kein Problem ist, die anzumelden. Bei so Sondersachen von irgendwelchen kleinen Firmen oder sowas, da empfiehlt sich ab und zu schon mal die Bedienungsanleitung dabei zu haben oder halt wirklich zu wissen, wie man dieses Deckt-Handy in ein fremdes System einbucht. Das müsst ihr dann machen, wenn ihr bei uns seid und uns natürlich die Rufnummer sagen, die ihr vorher registriert habt und dann startet die Telefonanlage eine Registrierung und fängt in einer gewissen Zeit an zu suchen, ob gerade dieses Telefon sich im Anwältezustand befindet und dann tauschen die gegenseitig so ID's aus, so eine Art Handshake und danach kennt dann die Telefonanlage das Telefon und damit ist auch die Rufnummer erreichbar.
Okay, das ist quasi das Äquivalenz zu Kabel reinstecken, wenn man jetzt das Ganze mal... Dann ist man drin und in dem Moment ist unser ne Nebenstellenrufnummer erreichbar. Wie weit reicht das? Reicht das bis auf den Alexanderplatz?
Das reicht bestimmt auch wieder bis auf den Alexanderplatz. Wir haben ja immer noch dieses Projekt, wir wollen im McDonald's telefonieren, ganz dekadent und uns gegenseitig anrufen.
Das ist aber ein bisschen weiter weg.
Also bis vor die Tür vom McDonald's geht's.
Oder meinst du das Burger King?
Nee, dann meine ich den Burger King.
Der der direkt am Alex ist.
Genau, es gibt natürlich auch noch McDonald's und Burger King und alles andere. Genau, aber das wollten wir irgendwie mal haben, so mit zehn Leuten da drin sitzen, sich gegenseitig anrufen und Audiokonferenz machen.
Sind dann spezielle Antennen dafür? Also ist das dann so eine Richtfunkgeschichte auch oder funktioniert das nicht mit Deck?
Man könnte da mit Sicherheit so eine Richtfunkantenne bauen, das ist ja auch ganz normal, 1,8 Gigahertz, so halt im normalen DSM-Bereich, ein bisschen drüber glaube ich oder ein bisschen drunter. Es gibt bestimmt welche, die wissen das ganz genau und schreien jetzt so aber ganz anders. Wenn ihr es wisst, dann könnt ihr natürlich auch irgendwie auf das Chaosradio Feedback drauf sprechen, wenn ihr wollt.
Genau, hätte ich halt glatt wieder vergessen.
Ganz gezieltes Product-Placement hier.
Wir müssen das wieder erwähnen, Chaosradio hat eine Feedback-Telefonnummer, wir möchten gerne, dass ihr uns anruft, wenn ihr was beizutragen habt oder wenn ihr auch nur irgendeinen Kommentar absetzen wollt, sag nochmal kurz die Nummer, 01801 99 33 22 99 55. Und da ist noch so was Anrufbeantwortungmäßiges und dann seid ihr schon fast mit dabei in der Sendung.
Könnt ihr uns auf unsere groben Fehler hinweisen?
So, und wie das funktioniert, das können wir auch gleich mal erklären. Ja, hier große Freude im Studio, Spaß mit den Reglern und den kleinen Fehlern der Software.
Gut, dass wir die Kamera nicht mitlaufen haben.
Das wäre ein Fest gewesen. Ja, nochmal hier zu den Telefonen. Wie viele nehmen denn da teil eigentlich? Wie viele Systeme sind wirklich angemeldet? Also wie viele Leute kommen und sagen, ich will jetzt mitmachen, wie viele sind eingebucht und wie viele telefonieren dann gleichzeitig?
Also auf dem What the Heck hatten wir ungefähr 1000 Leute, die mit dem Schnurlustelefon da waren und die auch alle ganz fleißig telefoniert haben. Natürlich machen jetzt nicht alle gleichzeitig, sondern es gibt auf dem letzten Kongress, der war, hatten wir so mal da immer wieder geguckt. Das waren also so zwischen 10 und 50 Leuten, die halt gleichzeitig telefonieren. Kommt natürlich auch immer darauf an, wie viele Leute zum Beispiel die Audio-Streams aus den einzelnen Vortragssälen hören. Ihr könnt also, wenn ihr draußen auf dem Flur steht und jetzt mal gerade in irgendeinen Saal rein hören wollt, einfach die passende Nummer dafür wählen und könnt quasi live reinhören in den Vortrag.
Was ist dann die Nummer?
Das könnt ihr beim Telefonbuch nachgucken. Auf eventphone.de gibt es ja das Telefonbuch und da gibt es dann Audio-Saal 1 bis 4 oder 3.
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht auswendig. Na ist ja auch egal. Können wir nochmal nachschlagen.
Könnt ihr jederzeit nachgucken.
Das ist ja schon eine ganze Menge. Also 50 Leute, die gleichzeitig telefonieren, so wenig ist das ja nicht. Heißt halt, dass permanent jemand da zum Apparat greift. Aber die Technik funktioniert ja in der Regel. Man kann aber jetzt auch nicht nur mit den Leuten telefonieren, die vor Ort sind, sondern man kann auch raus telefonieren.
Richtig. Und zwar könnt ihr dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal auf dem Kongress, auf dem Wort der Herr Cuttner das auch schon, aber jetzt zum ersten Mal auf dem Kongress, weltweit Festnetz kostenlos telefonieren. Das heißt für Lau Festnetznummer in der ganzen Welt anrufen.
Sozusagen im Eintrittspreis enthalten.
Genau, Vietnam, Amerika, Irak, Iran oder so. Wenn ihr eine Nummer habt, Festnetz, könnt ihr einfach anrufen.
Wie macht ihr das?
Das Ganze funktioniert natürlich wie alles, was kostenlos ist über das Internet.
Über das Internet. Als hätte ich mal so ein Hall-Effekt hier einbauen sollen.
Das ist ein System, das nennt sich Free World Dial-Up Out. Das basiert auf dem Give-and-Take-Prinzip. Man kann seine persönliche Telefonleitung zur Verfügung stellen für Telefonanrufe. Jeder Anruf, der über die Telefonleitung von einem geführt wird, dafür bekommt man ein Credit. Mit diesem Credit kann man wieder Anrufe machen. Wir wären nicht das POC, wenn wir da nicht ein großes Kontingent an Credits hätten, die wir euch einfach schenken dafür.
Mit anderen Worten, das gibt es alles kostenlos mit dazu.
Genau.
Wenn du unbedingt noch mal die Oma in Südamerika anrufen wollte. 22C3 ist der richtige Ort dafür. Kann man denn auch angerufen werden?
Ja, intern kann man natürlich schon angerufen werden.
Ich meine jetzt so von der Oma aus Südamerika zum Beispiel, wenn die noch mal zurückrufen möchte.
Also das sind wir im Moment noch in alle Richtungen am Ausschweifen und am Ausprobieren bzw. am Angebote reinholen, weil das sieht im Moment noch nicht ganz so gut aus, aber wir versuchen das noch hinzukriegen, dass wir dann auch wieder wie letztes Jahr eine Festnetznummer haben, Berliner oder sonstige Nummer, unter der ihr dann mit eurer Nebenstelle erreichbar seid. Falls das nicht gehen sollte, werden wir auf jeden Fall eine Möglichkeit machen, dass wir eine zentrale Nummer haben, wo man dann halt hinterher tippen muss, wen man gerne haben möchte. Das geht auf jeden Fall. Ah, mit Nachwahl dann.
Mit Nachwahl sozusagen oder auch mit Operator?
Wir können das natürlich auch mit Operator machen.
Das ist super.
Tim, würdest du dich dafür spontan zur Verfügung stellen?
Klar, so wie bei Office Space. Was gibt es denn noch? Also es gibt auch Anrufbeantworter in dem System, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Ja, da hast du richtig aufgepasst.
Voice Mail. Heißt das ja heutzutage. Anrufbeantworter. Ist eigentlich auch passender, weil kein einziger Anrufbeantworter hat jemals einen Anruf von mir beantwortet.
Deshalb ist es eine Voice Mail-System.
Und was macht das dann? Schickt mir das dann eine Mail? Nein, das ist eigentlich auch nur eine akustische Aufzeichnung und ich kann das über den Apparat abrufen.
Ganz genau. Ist das so wie beim Handy, die Mobilbox oder so was in der Richtung? Man kann die halt aktivieren, indem man eine Rufumleitung drauf macht auf eine entsprechende Nummer. Wie das alles funktioniert, dafür gibt es noch eine kleine Anleitung dann nachher auf eventphone.de. Also bis zum Kongress wird ihr auf jeden Fall fertig sein. Wird bei uns oben natürlich auch nochmal ausliegen. Wenn ihr irgendwie total die Probleme damit habt, einfach fragen. Wir sind für alle Fragen offen. Das funktioniert halt folgendermaßen, dass man da seinen eigenen Text aufsprechen kann oder halt auch einen Standardtext nehmen kann und dann hat man halt seine Mailbox, wenn man nicht vor Ort ist oder wenn man gerade nicht gestört werden will.
Es gibt ja auch noch so ein paar kleine nette Spielereien, die wir auch für die Organisation benutzen. Also ich erinnere mich hier, die Sanitäter haben auch so eine spezielle Gruppenschaltung.
Genau, die haben allerdings was ganz Besonderes. Die haben ja dieses Notfall-Evakuierungssystem. Das heißt, wenn die irgendwo einen Einsatz haben oder den koordinieren müssen, dann gibt es da ein spezielles Chaos Emergency Response Team Setup. Und das ist für das gleichzeitige Verteilen von Notrufnachrichten zuständig. Also wenn wir zum Beispiel den ganzen Kongress räumen müssen, was wir nicht hoffen, dann könnte man das auch über dieses System machen. Das würde dann nacheinander oder auch gleichzeitig.
Die Telefonanlage räumt auch automatisch den Kongress?
Richtig. Also wenn ich keine Lust mehr habe, dann sagt das mir alles viel zu voll hier. Knöpfchen, Druck und… Super.
Das spart eine Menge Arbeit. Aber es gibt ganz einfache Gruppenkonfigurationen. Also wenn jetzt so eine Gruppe sich gegenseitig anrufen möchte und sie möchten nur auf jeden Fall eine Person aus der Gruppe haben und es ist eigentlich egal, welche.
Genau. Wenn angenommen ihr seid zum Beispiel die OpenFu-Gruppe, dann kommt ihr einfach zu uns und sagt, ja, wir haben hier fünf Leute mit denen und den Telefonnummern, könnt ihr uns nicht eine Gruppennummer dafür machen. Dann überlegen wir halt mit euch, was am sinnvollsten ist, weil es gibt da verschiedene Arten von Gruppen. Erste Art von Gruppe ist, alle Telefone klingen gleichzeitig. Das heißt, wenn die Gruppennummer angerufen wird, klingeln.
Das ist so volle Panik.
Genau, dann überall klingelt es.
Wir wollen alles sofort mitbekommen und wir können gar nicht genug Fans haben.
Genau, dann gibt es halt die Möglichkeit, es bekommt immer der das Gespräch, der am längsten keins mehr hatte, so die faireste Methode und die, die am wenigsten gewollt ist vom entsprechenden, der da dran gehen muss. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch die Methode, es fängt immer beim ersten an und wenn der dann erst besetzt ist, dann bekommt der zweite erst mal anruf.
Von der Reihenfolge der Wichtigkeit.
Genau. Das sind so die drei Grundarten von Gruppen, die wir machen können und bekommt ihr halt noch eine zusätzliche Rufnummer zu den fünf Nummern, die ihr habt und dann seid ihr über diese Gesamtnummer halt komplett erreichbar.
Das ist ganz praktisch. Vor allem ist es dann praktisch, wenn nicht unbedingt immer alle auch wirklich vor Ort sind. Also so, das Kongress hat ja auch so eine gewisse 24-Stunden-Tendenz, da gibt es so den einen, der ist wohl eher vormittags präsent, so hat man über eine Rufnummer auf jeden Fall immer jemand aus der Gruppe erreichbar.
Der einem weiterhelfen kann.
Genau, der einem weiterhelfen kann, und wenn halt alle schlafen, na Gott, naja, mal halten.
Ja, wenn alle schlafen, dann gibt es ja den Weckruf.
Dann gibt es den Weckruf?
Genau, man kann sich einen persönlichen…
Und ja auch automatisch. Das ist jetzt so, seit einer halben Stunde keiner mehr rangegangen.
Na also, was automatisch kommt, sind die Weckrufe für die Engel. Die werden von Cookie mit einem Extrasystem gesetzt bei uns in der Anlage und dann ruft die Anlage halt die Engel an, Achtung, du hast gleich Dienst, Achtung, du hast gleich Dienst und man kann natürlich noch seinen persönlichen Weckruf programmieren mit einer Kennziffer und dahinter gibt man einfach die Uhrzeit vierstellig an und dann ruft ein das System zurück und Hello, this is your wake-up call.
Tausend Methoden, wachgeklopft zu werden auf dem 22C3. So, damit haben wir glaube ich so die Kernfunktionalität schon ganz gut abgeklopft, die er anbietet. Es gibt da noch ein paar lustige Spielchen. Was hat mit diesem Labyrinth auf sich?
Also der Bef bei uns im POC-Team hat ein Labyrinth gebaut bzw. ein Labyrinth im Telefon implementiert. Man kann quasi mit den Tasten vom Telefon durch dieses Labyrinth durchlaufen und bekommt dann über das Telefon gesagt, wo man denn gerade steht bzw. du stehst vor einer Wand, ein mittlerweile Spruch, der sich schon intern zum Running-Gag entwickelt hat, wenn irgendwer irgendwas will und dann du stehst vor einer Wand.
Und wenn man den Ausgang gefunden hat, dann hat man gewonnen?
Dann kommt man ins nächste Level und klettert natürlich einen Platz auf unserer Highscore-Liste nach oben, die man auch über die Webseite erreichen kann. Da steht dann halt, bis zu welchem Level man gekommen ist und wie schnell man war und für alle, für die das zu schwierig ist. Es gibt bisher noch keinen Preis, aber man kann ja 0 Euro mal sagen.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, so ein Tagesgewinner könnte bei euch auf jeden Fall mal einen Kaffee ziehen.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Das können wir einführen.
Ja, es gibt noch ein zweites Projekt, das sich unter Umständen noch mit anschließt. Das ist der Lars aus Hamburg. Der ist am Fummeln. Es ist noch nicht ganz klar, ob das was wird. Wir hatten das auch schon letztes Mal. Der alte Code, der Villa des Audioland-Systems wird reanimiert für den Kongress und dann auch an eure Anlage mit angeschlossen. Da ist jetzt darüber gesprochen worden, wenn ich das richtig sehe, das auch mit der Rufnummer-Datenbank zu verknüpfen, muss man mal schauen. Im Idealfall hätte man also noch eine kleine Cyber-Audio-Welt parallel mit dabei, wo man sich noch nicht mal, wo man noch nicht mal irgendwelche Pins eingeben muss. Man ruft halt einfach an und man wird ja sofort erkannt an der Nebenstelle. Ich denke, wenn das spruchreif wird, dann kann man das hier auch noch mal erwähnen. Ja, und jetzt bist du ja auch derjenige, der das Podphone eingerichtet hat. Das hatte ich hier auch schon mal erwähnt. Das ist dieses Live-Phone-Blogging, Phone-Casting, wie man das auch immer nennen soll.
Ja, Multi-User-Audio-Blog über Telefon. Kurz, M, B, U.
Es riecht ja ein neuer Trend. Das ist noch recht frisch, das habt ihr gerade erst aufgesetzt.
Ja, da kam mir die Idee, es gibt ja so diverse Ansätze schon mal überall im Internet. Einen Ansatz gibt es aus Amerika. Da hat man aber den Nachteil, es gibt nur eine amerikanische Nummer und man muss zwingend eine amerikanische Nummer haben, um das Ding benutzen zu können, weil er einen anhand der Absenderrufnummer erkennt. Wenn man da keine 13-stellige oder 14-stellige Telefonnummer oder wieviel die da halt haben, hat, dann geht das einfach nicht, auch wenn man da eine deutsche Nummer einträgt oder so. Das war dann schon mal so der erste Anreiz, da muss man doch mal was selber machen und...
Wie heißt der Dienst, den du da erwähnst?
Oh, das weiß ich jetzt im Moment. Ich hab irgendwie mal gesucht, Blog und Phone oder so und dann ganz schlecht recherchiert jetzt hier.
Okay, wir wissen das nicht, ist auch egal. Wie läuft das bei euch mit der Anmeldung? Das ist alles noch ein bisschen manuell, oder?
Genau, im Moment ist das noch ein bisschen manuell und befindet sich so in der Beta-Testphase. Aber wenn ihr da einfach einen Account haben wollt bei podphone.de, dann schreibt mir einfach eine E-Mail. E-Mail-Adresse findet ihr auch da in dem Text. Schreibt einfach, ich will mitmachen. Dann müsst ihr mir eine Pod-ID sagen. Das ist halt eure zum Beispiel Telefonnummer oder irgendeine Nummer, über die ihr euch identifizieren wollt und ein PIN-Code dazu. Und mit dieser Kombination könnt ihr dann euren eigenen Audioblog aufmachen, den ihr über Telefon einsprechen könnt.
Das heißt aber, auf dem Kongress ist das dann auch wiederum mit der Anlage gekoppelt. Das heißt, man kann eine bestimmte Nummer anrufen, muss sich gar nicht groß anmelden, sondern wird automatisch erkannt. Tralala, an dem Stelle sowieso. Ja, hallo, jetzt sag mal was auf deinen Speicher. Und dann plappert man das rein, legt auf und dann ist das schon im Podcast drin.
Richtig, ganz genau. Das plumpst dann hinten als Podcast raus. Man kann dann zum Beispiel gerade mal ein Kommentar zu irgendeinem Vortrag abgeben oder was man gerade so den Leuten mitteilen möchte. Und alle, die das dann abonniert haben, bekommen das dann sofort als Podcast, Faktik angeliefert, zum Beispiel in...
Und jetzt freu ich mich mal ganz kätzerisch, kann ich auch per Telefon Podcasts abonnieren? Gibt es also auch eine Rufnummer, wo ich alle von mir abonnierten Podcasts vorgelesen bekomme?
Das ist in Planung. Kann man natürlich einbauen. Muss man nur erstmal machen.
Muss man erstmal machen. Wird ein bisschen knapp. Okay, wir schauen's. Okay, ich würde sagen, dann können wir das auch mit belassen.
Ja, danke schön auch, dass ich hier sein durfte.
Na klar und wir werden hier ohnehin noch ein produktives Wochenende haben, hier in Berlin. Und ja, das war Chaosradio Express 006. Ihr merkt schon, der Express ist kräftig in Touren gekommen, hier in den letzten Tagen. Das wird wahrscheinlich jetzt bis zum Kongress noch ein bisschen so weitergehen. Aber zwischendurch gibt es dann auch mal wieder reine Informationssendungen und natürlich einmal im Monat das große, dicke, fette Talkradio Chaosradio. Ich bedanke mich jetzt erstmal fürs Zuhören und sag Tschüss. Tschüss.